what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at led live today we're going
to be talking about
what is it like to have the character of
christ find out on this episode of
led live
light exposing darkness
thanks for joining us today guys for
another week of led live i got my
brother darius here
we have a we have conversations like
we're in a marco
polo group if you know what that is and
there's a group of us guys in there and
we just like to fellowship with each
other and
encourage each other and share you know
things that we've been studying and
stuff
and man there's all of us all of us in
there are like darius i know the answer
he's just got this thing he's got the
word hidden in his heart
and so we wanted to invite him on the
show and i said what do you want to talk
about man he said
let's talk about the character of christ
man what a timeless
topic you know you can go so many
directions with the character of christ
but i think it's really important you
know a lot of times i think
christianity is just looked at as well i
said this little prayer i'm good to go
your life just kind of goes
on as normal but i think that there
should be a transformation in your life
a renewed character right
amen it should be it really should
because when you actually see the
creation of man
preferably when you look at genesis
chapter 1 verse 26
we see god having a conversation with
himself he says let
us create man in our image after our
likeness
so when man was first created he was
created to be like god and a lot of
people take this
this false twisted doctrine from that
and they believe that when god said let
us create man in our image
that somehow man was created like god in
his divine nature
and you get this theology that you guys
actually talk about a lot on your shows
where man is somehow a god and people
believe this
because they twist that scripture and
they fail to realize that when you
actually look in the hebrew like the
word
image and likeness it it means character
it's just like you see the same exact
thing in revelation chapter 13
where it says that people want that the
beast wants people to worship his
image so the beast is attempting to try
to get you to be in his character
just like god originally made man in his
character but when man sinned
he lost that character of god so this is
one of the reasons why christ had to
come to the earth
to show mankind what god was like he had
to remind
man who i am what i'm like so that you
can
fashion your life after this so that
people can see this so that people can
understand who i am
because we know that god's invisible to
us because the book of isaiah tells us
in isaiah chapter 59 verse 2
that your iniquities have separated
between you and your god and he's hid
his face from you because of our sins so
god is invisible to us because of that
and because we can't see god we needed a
divine representation
of god to come and be amongst man so
that we could start to live like that
and just like you were saying about the
whole entire thing of transformation
god is really big on relationships
god is really big on relationships and
god himself he's in that same verse he's
a relational god
and what's so cool about our god is that
when you look at the triune god you've
got the father
the son and the spirit they never
talk about themselves if you ever look
in the scripture the
the father never promotes himself it's
always about the son
but the son is like no father no no no
no it's all about
the spirit the spirit says stop it no
it's all about jesus
because he was like didn't i tell you
quit cut it out it's all about the
father
they're all other centered it's always
another centered thing
you see that in in god's creation
everything's always giving
yes the you know the rain gives to the
plants and the plants give to us
and it's just this big cycle it's all
about giving you're talking about the
the original lie in eden was you can be
like god you know my god
so yeah we're created in the image of
god and we should be like god but the
the false counterfeit is no you are god
you're divine
and that's what you see in the new age
world and and that's what's promoted in
so much of
hollywood that we expose and stuff all
the time is
to be you know to be god not to be
like christ and when you're saying we
can't see god
it's not that god is hiding he's not
like you know hiding
it's his in his mercy and grace that we
don't see him because we would be
consumed man we are so
impure that we can't even stand in the
presence of god and yet
he allows us to continue because he
wants all of he doesn't he's not willing
any of us to perish she wants all of us
to repent
receive salvation the gift of eternal
life so we can be forever
with him when in actuality he'd be
completely just in destroying us all
he could just show himself and we'd all
be disintegrated and he would be just in
that
because we are unclean of our own self
our own sins emmanuel right he wants to
be
with us and yeah i appreciate that that
god is such a relational god
everything you see in the bible you see
this dovetailed
marriage language you see this like you
know all of it deals with relationship
the ten commandments our relationship
with god our relationship with man
and so you know that's what got
distorted and
that relationship has been you know just
convoluted and jesus had to come and you
know
re-give us a a vision a picture of god
and
show us really what god was really like
because the devil had just clouded us
with years of darkness
i heard a really good illustration and
the guy who gave it was
chuck missler which he's got a lot of
good stuff i don't agree with everything
he says but
he was talking about how picture it
like a 2d image you know stick figures
on a piece of paper that's
mr and mrs flatts he called them they
they live in this flat world all they
know
is is basically like if i walk up to you
i see this flat figure and now if we're
in a 3d world
say we drew these characters and we want
to interact with those characters we
created these characters
how do we interact we live in this three
dimension they can't even comprehend
three dimension you know
we can we can fake it we can do like uh
you know draw a square and then another
square and connect the lines and it's
like okay this is like a
box you're seeing three dimensionally
and you can kind of give an illusion of
it but imagine if you had no concept of
what three dimensions was
that still just looks like a bunch of
lines like
i don't know i mean the the best way to
figure it out is like
we're three-dimensional beings how in
the world do we know what four
dimensions is
we can't even comprehend it and if god
or us were to interact with these
beings on the paper you know okay i'm
gonna go down there i'm gonna i'm gonna
go in there so i'm gonna stick my finger
through there all they're going to see
is suddenly a black circle and and the
more you put your finger in that circle
is just going to enlarge and large
until your hand goes in there and this
shape is going to it's just going to be
a
black shape they're not going to be able
to get the whole picture of who you are
because it's a whole different uh
dimension it's a whole different world
so god came down to be one of us to live
in our shoes and so that we could
actually see
wow that's what god is that's what god's
like this guy
jesus christ that is god in the flesh
but we can't even comprehend him you
know
but god jesus came down and and
dwelt among his people so that we could
see if you've seen me you've seen the
father seen the father
amen amen that's that's a there's
actually a scripture that he actually
says that that's
john 17 verse 3 when he says so that we
may
know him the only true god
in jesus christ when he sinned and it's
a very interesting parallel
that you were actually bringing up with
the
entering into the different dimensions
as well as
god not wanting to destroy us because
you know isaiah actually says that the
destruction of the wicked is a strange
act to god
but there's a question if you look in
matthew chapter 13 verse 55
and you know it's actually a joke
because they were making fun of christ
people don't see that and we all know
that any time you tell a joke there has
to be some sliver of the truth because
why else would you laugh
in matthew chapter 13 verse 55 the
question is posed
when jesus is there and he's doing
miracles like
is this not the carpenter's son they
were trying to be funny
but they didn't even understand that
what they were really saying was
true because they were attempting to try
to make fun of him because
joseph was supposed to be his earthly
father but as christ had always said he
only had one father and it was god
when you actually look up the definition
of the word carpenter a carpenter is
someone who
builds or restores remember in malachi
chapter 3 verse 6 it says i am the lord
thy god i change not
so god can only be who he is
all the time so when the question was
posed is this not the carpenter's son
remember the conversation that christ
had with philip when philip said show us
the father
and christ said have i not long been
with you and you still say
show us the father if you have seen me
you've seen my father
so the question that they asked to
ridicule him was actually a true
statement
is this not the carpenter's son the
carpenter the carpenter
he said if you've seen me you've seen my
father so if christ is a carpenter
the father is a carpenter a carpenter is
someone that comes in to build he built
our world
our world fell into sin he came to
restore our world
but then when you parallel parallel that
together to john chapter 3 verse 17
where it says that god sent not his son
into the world to condemn the world
but that the world through him might be
saved or restored
remember john 10 10 says that the thief
cometh not but to steal kill and to
destroy
so satan is trying to condemn us but the
father sent
his son the carpenter to come and redeem
and restore us
this is why it's so pivotal like when
you look at god's character
his relational character and christ
beckons to us and he says hey
in revelation behold i stand at the door
and i knock
he's trying to come in because what does
that what does a carpenter want to do
they want to come in and assess the
damage that's done to the building so
that they
know how to rebuild and to restore it
he wants to come in and to sup with us
and this is what you see him telling us
through his servant david in psalm
chapter 127 verse 1
except the lord build a house they that
build labor in vain he has to come in
and restore that foundation
and build that house upon him so that we
can be redeemed so that we won't be
condemned
it's interesting that like you know that
picture of jesus knocking at the door of
the heart right
and all he wants you to do is open up
the door of the heart you know and i
think about that all the time of just
like
you know that puts jesus outside yes
and and where he is in relationship in
in revelation there
is he's not inside of our heart i think
we as as
as the christian church as as the
believers of christ
i believe that that is what he wants he
wants to come
into our hearts and the the hardest
thing for us to do is
daily inviting them in yes and inviting
them in
yes yes that's a very good point and
there's just one thing that
when you were saying that you're making
me think about your guys's name
led or lls little light studio the light
exposing darkness
there's a scripture that many people
actually we overlook this we we read it
all the time
after john chapter 3 verse 16 but the
following verses are so powerful and i
think that it was
very uh divine it was a divine
providence that you guys name
is what it is because in revelation
chapter 18
around verses two and three we see the
scene that john the revelator sees he
sees this great angel
coming down and the world is illuminated
with his glory
but right after that he gives a stark
warning the same angel
he says babylon is falling is falling
okay but why is babylon falling well the
answer actually lies
it's in your name but it's also in john
chapter 3
and you start around verse number
19. it says and this is the condemnation
that light has come into the world
and men loved darkness rather than light
because their deeds were evil this is
why christ
like brother scotty was saying is
outside because people are rejecting
that light and just like you were
sharing earlier
our god is a consuming fire james says
that
in him is no darkness at all nor shadow
of turning
so he's just a constant light and his
light
is exposing the darkness what fellowship
does light have with darkness exactly
i mean yeah that's that's been a staple
thing that we've analyzed on this
on this channel is like you know here
god is asking to us
you know to walk in the light right if
you call yourself
a christian then therefore wouldn't it
make sense as you would walk in the
light
and and love the things of the light and
not love the things of darkness
and we're trying to separate these two
things and say look at
if you're calling yourself a follower of
god that don't watch
evil things and fill your mind with
darkness
because they can you can't serve both of
those one is going to win over the other
one
you're going to love one you're going to
hate the other one and so you know
be a child of the light walk in the
light amen we got
we got stickers and shirts to say what
would jesus watch
you know because we we still wear those
bands so what would jesus do you know
but we don't i don't think we think of
that specifically what would jesus watch
what would jesus wear would he be
showing off the sexual parts of his body
and stuff you know i mean it's
interesting
like jesus we made a video on fortnight
you know a video game where basically
the object is to kill
everybody around and be the last person
standing that's the object of the video
game it was
one of the most popular ones a few years
back and we got a lot of people that
make comments and say i'm a christian
and
there's nothing wrong with that and it's
like we've got to stop
divorcing our mind from the things of
god and the things of the world
and and and just because you know it's
fake and it's a little game
that has no bearing in some greater
thing when the very spirit of
wanting to kill everything and be the
last person standing
it's it's not that you're actually going
out and actually really killing people
but it's just that
it's that love of that spirit that that
that you're doing it you know romans 1
who knowing the judgment of god they
which commit such things are worthy of
death
not only do the same but have pleasure
in them that do that yeah imagine
that before video games if somebody was
just sitting around all day like man i
just want to kill that dude i'm just
yeah thinking about it all day long you
would say
there's there's something wrong with you
you need to this is a sin
you're doing this in your mind but satan
has turned it into something that's
fun and like wow i actually enjoy i'm
entertained by killing people
and then it's just like if you're
lusting in your mind all day that's a
sin
sin starts in the mind but well it's
okay to watch porn or whatever
like how do people do not abhor evil
turn away from it like you know if you
if you actually um
there's been studies where where um
cultures that
were not uh uh growing up with tv
and they would show them just you know
tv from the 60s which you watch it it's
very slow it's black and white
yeah it's that kind of stuff and they're
fearful i mean they're they're like you
know oh this is this is terrible and it
has a profound effect on them and
and you think about what most people
digest today is just we're exposed to so
much
evil and by beholding we become
change we're turning into those things
that we are
enjoying or or you know feasting our
eyes on
that's a very good point because that's
why king solomon was inspired to say
that as a man
thinketh in his heart so is he it's i
don't think that people really
understand that they think that these
digital
images somehow don't have a bearing on
their mind but whatever you
think jesus says in luke chapter 6 verse
45 for out of the abundance of the heart
this is what we're speaking and then
paul tells the church at corinthians
he says be not deceived evil
communications
corrupt good manners everything that we
see or do just like brother scotty was
sharing it has some type of bearing
and even secular science has proved that
everything
that we consciously see you remember you
can't erase it
so it's there it's just waiting to come
out come out
you can't call it out when you want it
to but it's just waiting it's just
lurking
um how familiar are you guys with uh
pastor joe cruz like the original
creator
of amazing facts yeah you know i haven't
actually watched a lot i know who he is
but i haven't actually watched a lot of
his work
everything i've heard is awesome he was
like i listened to that
every day it's powerful he's very
powerful a lot of his sermons his
segments are only like 15 minutes
interesting because he has like he did
the first amazing facts presents yeah
so they're like 15 minute segments like
every day and you could just sit there
and just listen
15 minutes might drop pretty much
you don't even need me to say anymore he
has a book i mean i don't know how many
books he has
my wife was just reading i mean she left
to read and she was just reading like
seriously like
half of the page and it's so much to the
gist i was like
girl that's a sermon right there i mean
seriously can you imagine a book
and i forgot the name but i will find
out
i've seen that i can't remember the name
of it myself i know which book you're
referring to
because he has a lot of powerful books
but he made a statement
that was like what you said earlier
about like the people
getting i guess we would call it
westernized by television
and this was when this is about the late
80s early 90s before he passed away
and at that time he actually said that
the average
child before they reached the age of 12
we'll see 30 000 deaths on television so
you can only
imagine now that was then
things have only progressively gotten
worse 30 000. so that number is just up
to 12. imagine the lifetime
and then imagine how there's more deaths
in movies now
in the lifetime you know in some of our
videos in the past
we showed a couple of the statistics of
the rise of like even just sexual
content
and it's like you know there used to be
one two
exposures every 10 minutes or so like
this and now it's just
i mean just the frequency of how you're
exposed to those things is just greater
and greater and greater
and now we've got things that are coming
out in the media like the seven deadly
sins anime that's like about
destroying the ten commandments that's
the purpose of the
of the video so you know the morality of
our world is just in utter decay and we
can see it
it does not take a rocket scientist to
pick your head up and just look around
the world and say
you know we we've we've lost our minds
we've gone bonkers
and you know what's more amazing to me
than this at the end of the world when
we are at our worst state our
weakest thing as humanity right where
literally the universe would look at
us and say it is impossible for these
people to follow god
and god says watch this i'm gonna show
you my greatest work
i'm gonna show you a group of people
that love me so much you can actually
stick a gun to their head
and say worship me on this day and
they'll say nope i'd rather
die than defile my god and i believe
that's
that's the where god is leading his
people
towards the end you are by your faith
you know you're gonna be
caught up or something yes no people
just know i prefer the fire
yeah they're going to be there i would
rather lose my life
than defy oh my god that joker moment
amen
we can pray for that too so you kind of
brought up
name so you first started by talking
about something was character what was
that image
image is character so i did a study on
this and actually
name is character as well so when you
look at the
third commandment that says thou shalt
not take the name of the lord thy god in
vain
we often look at that as like well you
shouldn't say omg
or you shouldn't take the name of jesus
in a slanderous way
which that's true that's good not to do
that but i think it's deeper than that
don't take my name in vain don't take my
character in vain
don't call yourself a christian oh yes
and live just like the world because
the world is judging what is a christian
by looking at you
we're supposed to be in the image of
christ right so right when people look
and say
what is a christian what's what's it
mean to follow christ and they look at
you over here and you're doing
everything like the world what's
different
um so that that name is character
and in romans 12 2 it says
and be not conformed to this world but
be transformed by the renewing of your
mind
that ye may prove what is that good and
acceptable and
perfect will of god we see over and over
where
you know jesus says like be perfect as
my father in heaven is perfect
and this is talking about a renewed mind
so think about this is
your forehead your mind it needs to be
renewed and transformed
and when the book of revelation is
talking about god's people in the last
days like
i was talking about these people who are
just we will die for you
revelation 14 1 says and i looked and lo
a lamb stood on the mount zion and with
him were 144 thousand having the
father's name
written in their foreheads we got to
know that a lot of the stuff
in prophecy is symbolic now you're not
going to have 144 000 people with
you know yeshua or yahweh or something
written on their foreheads
this is his character in their mind that
they have that transformation power they
have the
renewed mind and you know this was
what it's talking about in the bible and
it says they had a form of godliness but
we're denying the power thereof
there's a lot of people today that have
a form of godliness i go to church every
week i have a bible i pray every day
but the power to overcome sin that
victory over sin
that's the power thereof that they're
denying no i'm going to watch my movies
you know
i'm gonna drink beer and stuff it's okay
it's cool they're not having that
transformation experience and i think
that's
a major part of becoming a follower of
christ
following your lord and master another
connection to um
name being symbolic for character
remember the story of moses when he
said i want to see you god now i love
this story because it's like
i try to imagine myself there lightning
going crazy
stuff blowing up you just know you're in
the presence of something
crazy amazing right and you're going to
step up and be like
i want to see you show me who you are
right i mean i would love to say see god
like i can't wait for the moment that we
get to
actually set our physical eyes on on god
right
and i love how god responds to this he
puts him in the cleft of the rock he
puts his hand over him and he walks by
him do you remember what he said
he declared his name and to him he
declared his name
so the way that he was showing moses
who he was was literally telling him
what his character was like and i think
that was beautiful
you know what i mean like like like what
a relational god
right not just that you physically see
me but you know
who i am that's right that's amazing
that's right man that's the god that we
serve and that's the god that he wants
everyone to see
and because i was just gonna say because
it's such a relational thing you
you become like people that you're
around
exactly when you're you're a lot like
your parents in different ways you know
because you grew up around them and then
you grow up and you might
change but then you're like people you
hang out with a lot you know
and and if people want to see god they
they need to see somebody who spent
time with god in their their
character is being transformed you know
yeah the book i was telling you about
uh is by your cruise and it's creeping
compromise
i think when you look at the stories in
the bible um you can constantly see this
theme that that god's people have walked
away from him
and they've compromised over and over i
mean you just you just take your bible
and you just flip through and read the
little titles at the top of
some of the old testament chapters in
there and i mean it's like israel falls
praise to idolatry israel falls prey to
idolatry i mean we were
constantly chasing after other gods
getting distracted with this and i think
that a big majority of that was this
creeping compromise
that's why god said when he brought the
children of israel out of the land of
egypt he said listen
don't intermingle with them don't have
them around you because
simply by observing their lifestyle
you're going to fall prey to that just
like at the uh
at the bell pure you know like like um
right before they were
gonna cross over into the land of jordan
and and balaam
you know gets asked to come and curse
the children of israel right
and and he tells the many united kings
like look it doesn't matter if you send
your whole entire army into this group
you cannot win like like they are
already committed to god and god will
protect them through and through
and you would have your entire armies
destroyed but then balaam goes home and
thinks about it and says you know what
yeah
you know how to really get to him he
goes i want the money so i'm going to
come up with a plan
all you got to do is is get them to
worship something other than their god
and then
then god's presence will leave from them
which is god's protections this is true
and you can have you can have your way
with them and that's exactly what they
did they just sent
women into their camp and they just
started inviting them to the parties
just just come you know just just watch
how we worship our gods
and that simply was israel just
observing their festivals and there was
a massive apostasy at that point
so why are we any different today we're
not if we're
watching how the world is parting
watching how the world is
is worshipping you know they're
worshipping celebrities the celebrities
know they're getting worshipped right
we're observing all of this idolatry how
are we not going to fall prey to that
yeah so the in the opposite of those who
have the father's name and the forehead
in revelation
17 5 it says and upon her forehead the
mind
was a name character written mystery
babylon the great mother of harlots and
abominations of the earth
um so you just see like these two polar
opposite
groups of characters of people in the
end times you know
we have to take this we have to take
this seriously
about the character our character i
think a lot of people have a
misunderstanding what the 666 mark of
the beast
really truly is all about um a tattoo
or a whatever that's gonna you know it's
a vaccine or something like this right
microchip when really why it's placed
upon the forehead you have your frontal
lobe behind your forehead
and in your frontal lobe is your seat of
your morality your spirituality and your
will
and when you place um that mark on the
forehead
you have to remember that god also
promises there will be a mark for his
people on the forehead
the seal of god and his name and his
name and his character that's actually
placed on
that means that the character of christ
is on the mind of that person
and the devil has a counterfeit for that
and his counterfeit is
his character his mindset on it
and 666 you know it's like the the
number of a man right that's
the way the bible speaks about it right
man was created on the sixth day
it's like man is the top of the food
chain you are the pinnacle of your all
existence you know i mean that's
that's why jay-z all those guys are
constantly doing this
is because their worldly system is built
on
man being at the top that's right
whereas god's system
is we aren't on top god is on top he's
on the throne of our hearts
and that's that's why the difference
between the two things
of of the you know mark of the beast as
opposed to the seal of god
what made me think about this mother of
harlots and mystery babylon in the name
and all that was because you're talking
about israel
what how did god describe it when his
people strayed off
because he's a relational god we're like
in a marriage with god we're supposed to
be in a marriage he's the bridegroom why
are you chasing harlots yes so when you
go off he said you're going a whoring
this is the of babylon there's two
women in the book of revelation and
one's a pure white woman that's a church
signifying god's people that he's coming
back for his bride
his his uh his girl is woman you know
her love and affection is for her
husband that's right
and she's in the white you know she's a
virgin uh the
you know christians are often referred
to as virgins and some of the other
parallels
but then there's this harlot and you
know some people when they're just
reading this stuff
do they really comprehend what all this
is you know it's like read it
yeah just read it but you're a whoring
after
something that's not the way god
designed it you know you know it's a
very interesting concept like all of
that when you start there
they're whoring after this concept
that's alternate from god
you know paul tells us in his letters to
timothy he said in first timothy 16 he
said that the love of money is the root
of all evil right
so people take that and they stop there
but there's a problem with that concept
because there wasn't any money in heaven
and
satan or lucifer at that time coveted
something more so the love of money in
and of itself
isn't the pinnacle of the evil it's
because someone wants
more they want more than what god is
offering that's what makes you go a
whoring after that's what made the fall
of man in genesis 3
because eve coveted something more than
what god had offered and this is what
would make you cheat on your spouse
because you
think that something out there is better
and then it goes back to the thing that
scotty was talking about in revelation
13 with the number being the number of a
man
when you look at this the statue that
nebuchadnezzar had in his dream
in daniel it actually says that it was a
statue of a
man it was a statue of a man and who was
it that had to come and destroy that
image of a man christ it had to be
christ he has to destroy that image
because satan what satan is attempting
to do just like all of you are saying
he's trying to get man to believe just
like he did in eden
that somehow man is a god in and of
himself
and what satan will come and do and mark
it with his authority
to say i approve in the form of god
i approve of you being the god of your
own life
i approve this is why we see paul in his
letter to the church at thessalonica
he says that that day shall not come in
second thessalonians chapter three
chapter two in verse three and four he
said that they shall not come speaking
of the second coming of christ
lest there be a falling away first and
that man of sin
be revealed who opposes
all the things of god so that he sits in
the temple of god
showing himself that he is god and a lot
of people automatically when we look at
prophecy oh it's the pope
it's the pope no we
are the ones that want to sit in our own
temple
and rule over god god is the only one
that should be sitting here
but you know what's so amazing about the
god that we serve
we all want to be on the throne of our
hearts right right but the second god
says
let me rule on the throne we get off
we let him on the throne of our hearts
and what does he do
he reaches down and he picks up our hand
and he rules on us with us
we basically get what we want yeah right
yeah we basically get what we want
it's just that giving up to
to jesus and saying lord i want you to
be the driver amen
you are the one that that that you know
i will respond to whatever you tell me
to do and and
he will be the king in our hearts
because he will change the desires of
your heart we
we desire so many things that destroy
our lives and our bodies and
you know there's a lot of things i i
thought that i wanted back in the day i
thought i wanted to be like a famous
metal in a metal band or
a rapper with this clothing line and i
was close i mean i could have had that
if i just
pursued it but when god said you can
have this or you can
follow what i have for you and i truly
was at a point where i wanted to do
god's will i surrendered and let let him
in
and god has made my biggest dreams come
true man like
i get to use the talents i have to work
here and we
i do make t-shirts and we do make videos
and
we do promote it to the world we pray
for people too yeah
and it's like god has so much
better for you if i would have had my
way man i'd be
probably passed out drunk somewhere and
you know who knows where i'd be right
now but
god if like you said he gives you what
you want but he gives you what you truly
would you truly want you see i think god
knows
all of us better than we think we know
ourselves that's true i can i can
remember when i was in hollywood and i
would go out on auditions
and um you know i was a christian when i
grew up in christianity when i went to
hollywood
my idea was i'm gonna become famous so
that i can
promote god of course six months later
i'm you know
not even anywhere near anything god
and i i would go to auditions and i
would pray i would say lord if you give
me this
i'll i'll turn around i'll give it all
back to you i'll put it in the churches
i'll do whatever like this right
and i never booked anything of any sort
of significance right
and i was frustrated i spent that spent
10 years out there trying to like really
try to make it in this
in this industry and um i look back on
it now and i go praise
praise god that i didn't make it praise
god that i
he didn't answer my prayer but he did in
a way that i didn't even understand
i needed and now i look back on my life
and i go if i would have made
millions or made it famous i don't know
if i'd be sitting here with you guys
right now
and so that path that god has has
allowed me to travel
it's like i have this whole different
perspective and i tell you what
more than anything i ever dreamt as a
kid wanting to be famous and wanting to
have lots of money and everything else
there is no satisfaction like you hear
somebody giving their heart to christ
i go that's it i don't even need to make
any money
like literally that was my payment right
there like
i get like excited about that guy oh me
too
like you said he knows us better than we
know us and he's given us what we truly
want because all of us
truly want eternal happiness
and hope and and you know
that's what i'm looking for just like uh
peace you know that's what we really
want and look at the celebrities
they have everything but they don't have
peace they don't have hope they don't
have true friends they can't trust
anybody so even though we think we want
that no this is what i want god this is
what i want god
he's saying no believe me you don't i
know what you really want i'm trying to
give it to you a peace that passes all
understanding yeah it's just like the
saying though like when you're saying
about the celebrities there really is no
rest for the wicked you know
they're never at risk i remember i think
it was um roger morneau
do you ever watch his stuff i think it
was him that said that the demons won't
rest
until they like actually cause you to
sin
like they'll just keep you awake and
alive and
and and doing whatever and and it's like
their one goal is to get you into that
space
and they'll just keep trying at it and
trying at it and and
uh i think i remember hearing that from
him and thought about that concept and
just went
yeah man they they that's their one
mission and one goal
you know they won't let you go to sleep
that's crazy that's that just shows you
how
tormented and demented they are how they
become because they've separated from
god
but praise god for his grace amen the
word sin abound
amen grace did much more abound so so
let me ask
how did you how did you come into all
this i mean was there a
sort of a history of way back when and
what was your transformation
i think brother mikey has saw it there's
actually a uh
i know you've seen it the testimony on
my life
on amazing facts awesome though i
actually have a testimony on my life
we'll put that link in the description
below for you guys to watch then i've
actually uh actually shared it
with uh brother alex i was on just be
blessed i've seen your testimony awesome
i've seen your testimony on that yeah
subscribe to you
share your testimony with him but just
it's really interesting
like you both were just sharing what
people don't really understand
god really knows and understands us
better than we could ever imagine to
begin to understand ourselves because
jeremiah tells us that our hearts are
deceitful above all things and i'm very
very cognizant when i see those words in
the bible all
and every everything it says that all
things our heart is more deceitful and
wicked than
all the things that you can imagine is
that who can know it that means you
don't know yourself
so god does know us best and just like
you were sharing earlier
that's what christ says in matthew 6 33
when he says seek ye
first the kingdom of god and his
righteousness
and all these things will be added to
i'll give you everything that you ever
desire but i'm going to give it to you
in the right way
and what's so fascinating about that is
when you look in romans chapter 2 verse
it's a concept that just blew my mind
but i'm starting to understand it better
and better each day
it says knowing not that the goodness of
god
is what leads to repentance it's not
that people like oh
they look at god hell fire and brimstone
keep the commandments no
right what changes your life is the fact
that god
rescued you from where you were he's
freed you from where you were he
brought you to him that's what makes you
want to serve him it's like wow you
you're amazing you're amazing the fact
that and and
we've brought this up on the show a
couple of times the fact that jesus
being god like equal with god right
was willing to take this like humble
road to come down here to this planet
literally subject yourself to
whatever we deal with right and then
also to give up your
life i mean a lot of people don't think
of the of the um
actually universe's perspective of this
situation
no being of angelic the angelic host
none of satan none of satan's angels no
one has died
literally not one celestial being
outside of the human race
has died that's true and god was willing
to come down here on this planet
and snuff out his life lay it down
allow the devil to to have him like that
and even even i love how some some
um ways that it's spoken of jesus could
not see through the portals of death
meaning he wasn't even sure if his
sacrifice would be accepted by god
and he said i don't care i'm going to do
it anyway because i want to give these
guys a human
a a chance to live forever so jesus was
willing to
cease to exist so you can exist forever
what a love oh man that blew satan's
mind
yeah i bet it did
i guarantee you the dark ages that
happened
he just went crazy he just lost his mind
how can that being
love these little things so much that
he'd be willing to do that and it just
he couldn't grasp it that's what's so
great about
like oh about relationships like
everything that you said
what is the the basis of life and the
basis of all relationships are defined
in the crucible
of time that's all that life is yeah
that god was so
loving that he was willing to do
everything that scotty said
he was willing to give up his time for
us
because god is based in the essence of
eternity he was literally willing to
give up time
and think about it most of the shows
like i watch some of your you guys live
stream and i see some of the comments
and the things that people say and
people get upset because you're telling
them hey
you shouldn't play this game or you
shouldn't watch this anime because it's
doing this predictive programming
most of the biggest issues that we have
in this life
is people do not want to give up their
time
they don't want to give up their time
they would rather go watch dragon ball
right they would rather go watch these
horror films you're interrupting my time
you're taking away from my time you're
inconveniencing my time that's what they
all say
but there's one verse and that verse
it it points out exactly what brother
scotty was saying
in john chapter 15 verse 13 people
automatically assume
that they take it they take it very
literally when jesus says greater love
have no man than this
that he lay down his life for his
friends and they only stop at the
physical aspect
but what is life consisted of time
he said no greater love have no man than
this that he'd give up his time for you
christ was really he was willing to lay
down eternity
to give it all up he's i'm willing to
give up my
time forever if this is what it took to
win
to win this world just to win i'm
willing that's
it and that's what i don't think people
grasp that and and that is
why the whole heavenly host is like
that's my commander-in-chief that's who
i want to serve
i mean i mean it just it just won the
hearts of of all them
turn their back on satan at that point
if he could kill christ
he could do the same thing to you and i
that's right and that's when they all
said no yeah it's like a line in the
sand like
they're not gonna none of the righteous
angels at this point
are ever gonna change their mind because
they saw it no we we saw what happened
you can't take that back
and uh that's the way it's going to be
when when we finally do get to eternity
god is allowing all this to play out so
that sin will never rise a second time
we will always have this this experience
as a memorial to look back on
if if ever in eternity we were ever like
the thought of sin were to come up nope
i remember this person that you know
just the history of the world you know
the the
hitlers and the prostitution and the
drug deals and all this stuff like
it'll never rise again because the
experience you tell a kid don't touch
the outlet
don't touch the outlet they think you're
keeping something from they touch the
outlet they'll never do it again
and that's the way these angels are you
know they've seen wow
they saw the true colors of satan at
that moment and the true colors of
christ you know
that's a very good concept i remember
there was a preacher that said those
same words
to me he said whenever you think of sin
and eternity christ is going to raise
his hand and say you remember this and
you're like oh yeah
my bad my bad my bad my bad
eternal memorial yeah isn't that isn't
that neat like that will be
like a a seriously majestic thing that
he retains those
yeah you know because if it you know in
heaven everything is perfect and
everything is
is well done yet you have this physical
remembrance of it right there
and i love how how you know through
eternity
you know we we probably are like a
distant memory
we will remember it happened but it
won't be like you know the details will
get a little bit less and less but when
we hang out with christ we'll be like
oh yeah i remember now
you know this was this was why you had
to come and die for us
[Music]
and through that way that he loves us
this is the character of christ
he loves us so much so much
that he's like let me take the
punishment for you i mean at that point
who
how can you fight against that i i
came across a video the other day um or
maybe it was you showing me or something
when
where um you guys were having one of the
leds
and i wasn't here and you played a clip
or kendy played a clip in the beginning
where the guy was like
what jesus gave up a weekend oh yeah
and i was just like that hurts my ears
and that boils my blood because what do
you mean he gave up a weekend
please tell me what has the devil done
yeah right please tell me what he's done
other than
ruin everybody's life and smash a bunch
of stuff
he didn't lay down his life but the king
of the universe did
i want to serve that god amen that's the
only way a person could even begin to
say
something like that is because they
don't understand what you've been
sharing
when you don't understand the character
of god it opens up your mouth to
say such words like that when you begin
to understand
everything that you just shared how
could you even like
fathom a thought like that yeah that he
loved you so much that he was literally
willing to
the king of the universe had all the
riches everything at his command he
didn't have to
but he was willing to come and just i'll
give it up right so opposite of what
lucifer in heaven was wanting more
yet christ was like look i'll take less
you know i mean you can see the very
the very like foundation of how heaven
operates
it is a foreign thought to me no money
right no money so you're going to be a
farmer and you're just going to kind of
grow stuff and like give it to
everybody right i mean look at what's
happening in our world i i came across a
statistic
the other day and they were talking
about millennials investing into the
stocks and stuff
and and they were saying out of all the
ones that have invested in the stock
white millennials in between a certain
age have
92 percent of the wealth
now i looked at that and i just went
this is not
like a like a consistent like
demographic it's not spread out evenly
i'm sorry i'm just gonna call for what
it is like like
that's that's that's us going i'm gonna
take as much as i can i gotta get mine
before you gotta get yours mentality
and it's like i'm gonna store up so that
the rest of you die there's so much
wealth in this world
so much wealth that there should not be
a starving child
in this world and it's because the
character
of that wealth is this is mine
and i'm not going to share it with you
that's why christ said it's harder for a
rich man to enter into the kingdom of
heaven
than it is for you know the camel to go
through the eye of me yeah
yeah if people want to blame god if
god's loving and all this stuff why is
there starvation and all this look at
yourself
look in the mirror what are you what are
you doing for the world yeah you got
all this and you're not going over there
but the ones who do go over there
are most of the time christians they're
the ones that are going to these third
world countries and building churches
and schools and wells and bringing
supplies and food and stuff
they have the character of christ give
what you've done to the least of these
you've done to me
that's right i i googled one time in
fact i'll do i'll do this again right
now
um how much money um would it take
to solve world hunger have you seen this
this is this is kind of a mind-blowing
statistic
uh like here's how much it would cost to
end world hunger
um there's a lot of articles that will
come up and and and say okay there's
about 800 million people that really
need
um feeding and they said that uh
really it's it's about 265 billion
dollars
would would end world hunger that's
probably how much the
america's in debt or something you know
you look at you look at how much money
is generated and just
buying christmas gifts
and and and we don't put things into
perspective like that we don't
say you know do i really need this do i
really need that
like like you remember the schindler's
list movie do you remember that yes and
then the very end of the movie he's
walking around and he pulls off his ring
and he's like i could have bought a
couple more people with this
i guarantee you that's how we're going
to feel at the end of this world it's
like
couldn't we have saved more people with
more resources you know
dude check this out so you just said a
range from
7 billion to 265 billion per year
that's a big but either way
on average american on the average
american will spend
700 on holiday gifts and goodies this
year totaling
more than 465 billion
dollars the nation retail that's twice
that's twice as much money as it would
take to solve world hunger
junk dude what are we really buying
people stuff that they don't
want or they use it it's going to break
or whatever
it's all going to burn in the end man
it's just the united states i mean what
about the whole world
maybe everybody you know yeah contribute
and see this is this is where people you
know they they get a little foggy on
on what does it mean to have the
character of christ versus the character
of the devil
the 666 or the you know others focused
i'll lay down my life so that you can
have a better existence
that's the character of god and all of
the heavenly host
i'm gonna get mine before you get yours
and i'm gonna take the best piece of the
pie with the best piece of land and i'm
gonna have the
the greatest thing that is the character
of the world yeah that is
that's a very shameful thing a very
shameful thing because
what you were showing or what you were
sharing reminds me
of what paul says to the church at
ephesus
in ephesians chapter 5 verse 25 he says
husbands
love your wives as christ loved the
church
and gave himself for it and people don't
people don't understand that emphasis
because of course it
speaks on marriage but it also speaks on
the fact of if you are a believer in
christ
you're married to him so you're his
bride so if i was a single man
i'm supposed to love others just like
scotty was saying
and we see that that same example in
philippians chapter 2 verse 3
where it says to let nothing be done in
strife or vain glory
but in lowliness of mind let us esteem
one another
better than self that's what christ did
he didn't come to be served he came to
serve the greatest
being in the universe he came to serve
right he came to serve him he was other
sin that's
my mind the the night before jesus
is laying down his life they're arguing
who's going to be the greatest
in their inner thing now that that that
story
was was one of those stories that really
just humbled me
saying these guys were in the very
presence of christ
they walked around they saw the miracles
firsthand they
knew who they were dealing with right
yet they're
still arguing who's going to be the
greatest
that is the the old man that we need to
die lay him down say it is no longer me
but christ that lives in me that helps
me make those decisions i don't want
myself myself has got to go away
and we have to have an others focused a
servant
attitude and and the fact that jesus was
so humble
in the way that he was doing that was
just mind-boggling what you said is so
important because you're talking about
dying to self and and changing but how
do we get that change it's not
it's not of our own strength that's what
we needed to talk about too yep
this is not your own strength you're not
just going to be like well i'm going to
go to the soup kitchen and all this
stuff that's right it has to be
the power of the holy spirit because our
true self is enmity against god
so we're not going to lay down or do
anything on our own accord
that is only that is only a surrender to
the holy spirit that would even allow us
to do that
that's right that's that's what jesus
tells us
through his prophet jeremiah he says and
you will seek me and find me but how
and you search for me with all your
heart and how do we do that
i remember it was a quote from one of my
favorite writers
he said we cannot give god our hearts we
have to
beg him to come in and take it wow
because just like you were sharing in
romans 8 7 about us being an enmity
against the law of god because our
carnal mind we
and i looked up that word enmity it
means that we are
against we are against we're rebellious
we literally hate it
we don't want anything to do with god in
our natural state
so you have to beg god
please take my heart from me i can't
give it
please take this money you have to
because the things that you guys are
sharing
what people don't understand when when
you share the videos that you do and you
say hey guys this has witchcraft in it
or this has this in it
you don't need to be messing with this
when they reject
that light that's being shared that's a
form of rebellion
and the more you rebel the more you
accept that it's just like you were
sharing
earlier whoever you hang out with
is who you begin to start to resemble
when you rebel against god it's kind of
like
someone asked me before they said how do
you blaspheme the holy spirit i said
okay i have a perfect example by god's
grace
so when you wake up in the morning you
have your cell phone let's say you use
it as an alarm clock let's say you have
to be at work
at nine right you got to be at work at
nine o'clock in the morning
and you're tired from the previous night
you stayed up too late
and your alarm goes off at eight and you
have a snooze button you hit that snooze
and it gives you 15 more minutes but
you're like i'm really tired i know i
can make it to work in about
20 minutes and you hit that snooze again
and you start to make this
a habitual thing you're hoping that
you'll get to work on time you're hoping
that traffic won't be out you
don't have a wreck or anything people
pulled over but eventually
what's going to happen is you're going
to hit that snooze so many times
that the alarm is going to be silent to
you you're going to start to ignore the
alarm and you're not going to hear it
you're going to be late to work you're
going to get written up you're going to
possibly lose your jobs the same thing
with the holy spirit
when someone is sharing that light when
you're saying hey guys
i'm not saying this to be judgmental i'm
not saying this to ridicule you i'm not
saying this to just take away your fun
but this is what i know to be true from
god's word this is what i'm seeing
this does not reflect who our god is you
don't need to have any fellowship with
this
and when someone continues to reject
that the holy spirit
is being deafened a little bit more wow
a little bit more and a little bit more
until finally they can't hear him
calling him because they've separated
himself from them and that was that was
kind of the experience that the
that the pharisees had right right it's
like they're around him they see the
miracles
they have these discussions like man
nobody can do this kind of stuff unless
you're you know with god
and yet then they're still like well
show us something
yeah jesus is just sitting there going
uh yeah
there's probably nothing i'm gonna show
you that would change your mind
at this point the evidence is all
presented before you
if you don't believe at this point i
could cause fire to come down from
heaven and it wouldn't even change your
mind
so i think that's the point that god is
getting in the end of the world too
as well the wheat in the tares is
growing up completely right you are you
are either
on god's side or you are not and
and at this point god
literally when he comes down and he says
okay enough is enough this whole thing
is over
it wouldn't matter if this thing
continued thousands and thousands and
thousands of years more
they've made their decision and at that
point
it's like there's nothing more that we
can do
so to finish up what you're saying
blasting the holy spirit is to what like
just
continually resists that that we would
call it conscience but the holy spirit
to keep resistant resistance and
resistance that's the holy spirit that
you're resisting so
at some point in time genesis talks
about god says my spirit will not always
strive with man
that's his spirit that's drawing you to
all truth but you continue to reject
reject reject
there comes a point in time when you no
longer hear that anymore that's the
blasphemy that wasn't exactly
the holy spirit that's how that like
like again you guys name that light is
trying to expose the darkness to you
like hey
don't go down this path don't go this
way and you're like no i'm gonna go
anyway
and as you walk that light starts to get
dimmer
and dimmer and dimmer until you can't
see it anymore and you're just stuck in
the middle of darkness
and you have no hope you can't you try
to run left or right and you never see
the light again
and that's what happens that's why it's
such a crucial thing because
paul tells us in ephesians 4 30 he says
to grieve not the holy spirit of god
by whom you are sealed into the day of
redemption so if you grieve away the
holy spirit you have
no chance of redemption this is why
david is crying he says
take not thy holy spirit away from him
because he knew if the holy spirit is
gone
there's no hope that's right that light
is gone there's no hope for you
and right now i mean we have
we have time i mean the doors of uh
mercy mercy is open i mean don't wait
until
i mean i'm sure we have testimonies
right when
it was so bottom i mean like so low
you hear that god he was reaching that
person yeah in the middle of
craziness man i pray and god it was dead
so let's not wait you know until the
last
last minute right now i was giving some
presentations in florida once
and one of the ladies that invited me to
come and speak at their church
um she used to be part of the wiccan
religion and
um as we kind of just were dialoguing
and stuff i was asking her because i
didn't know
really i've never met somebody firsthand
like part of that religion and i was
like well what is it like tell me like
do you go to this kind of churchy
event or like what are you doing she
said well it's actually ironically
there's a lot of things that are kind of
like like you would kind of think like
christians you know you get together
they sort of have these prayer sessions
and she said my particular group would
get together and we would pray over the
spirits that are around the emergency
room in the hospital
and she said we would specifically wake
up at 3am in the morning
and pray that the spirits would have
power over
anyone else in the hospital and and
keep those that were on their deathbed
from making a decision for christ
now now i just kind of sat there and the
hair went up back on my neck and i said
do you know why it's so important for us
to pray for people in the hospital
and i said why a hospital and she told
me something really interesting she said
because
god is so merciful that he will
literally come to those people on their
last dying breath and say
will you will you choose me and
they're preventing god or his angels to
do that
so so the patience and and and long
suffering that god has is
is endless if he could save you at your
dying breath
he would do it that's not god's
character
that's god's character but don't wait to
that point
then we start having the alarm clock
experience
don't be too late now
wow not willing that any should perish
that's right that's an amazing god
yeah final thoughts how you want to wrap
this up man it's
nothing else matters but god's character
when you understand who god is the world
think about the problem with the world
is like you were sharing this earlier
about
how people view christians the world
accepts reputation but reputation is
something that the enemy came up with
people always want to protect their rep
i want to protect my image i want to
protect how people view me
hollywood is all about the image you
meet those people in real life and
you're like you're not like
anything you were on tv isn't that
interesting that the whole thing is
built around an image
so you see this all satanic that
but that's not character character is
who you really are
even in the midst of the thick of the
fire
he never changes it's who you really are
when no one's looking
that's right it's like i know that when
i was in the military
we always one of our core values was
integrity first
integrity integrity it means that like
you say it uh
doing the right thing even when no one
sees you
always being on your best behavior at
all times
that's exactly what i was looking for
integrity is being the same person you
are
in public as you are behind closed doors
vice versa
so darius before we get finished here
give us some practical
advice for maybe some of our viewers
that are watching like
where do they start how do they begin to
either
understand the character of christ or
invite the character of christ
where do you start well for me by god's
grace
it has to be a self-sacrificing thing
and i point to the sanctuary service
because people look at that and they
automatically assume that it's
only god's way to save man but david
says in psalm 77
13 thy way is in the sanctuary so that
means that
everything about god even in perfection
is in the sanctuary and when you think
about it
we should begin our day like daniel in
daniel 1 8 it says that daniel purposed
in his heart that he would not drink the
wine of babylon
he purposed it so we have to be
intentional first thing you should do
when you get up is be intentional to
sacrifice your day
that brings you to the altar of
sacrifice sacrifice yourself
and your day to god and what should you
do you should be begging and pleading
with god
to give you the holy spirit to wash you
and to make you clean and to refresh you
which brings you to the altar uh to the
labor
so you're being washed by the holy
spirit and then you need to pray you
definitely need to pray consistently
throughout the day first thing in the
morning last thing before you go to bed
which brings you to the altar of incense
and when you're doing that you need to
ask god to be with you this is how this
relational
thing happens when you're spending time
with god and his word at the table show
bread
you're getting to know him better you're
getting to understand his ways better
and then that light of the holy spirit
is given to you in the seven branch
candlestick
which prepares you to enter into the
most holy place with god on a day-to-day
basis
and you can rest in your mind knowing
assuredly
that god is going to help you he's going
to take over he's going to be able to
allow you to
apply uh practical biblical applications
into your life it's little things
like you and i were talking one time
people don't understand
he said how do i evangelize do i just
run out to people and say you should
keep this out i'll say no no no i said
do like jesus
jesus dwelt amongst the people as one
who sought their good
and once they saw that he really cared
once they saw that they could trust him
then he said follow me that's why a
majority of his ministry
on earth was in the healing he was
administering to their day-to-day i mean
when you're when you're dying right you
know the last thing is like you know
you're like you know
wanting to know all these like doctrinal
issues you're like
i'm barely breathing here help me out
and he and he
literally like administered to their to
to their things
showing his his care just for their
well-being and what i love too is
like nowhere in one of those things did
he go well
did you go to church no did you did you
did you spend 15 minutes of morning
reading and spending time with god
because i'm not going to heal you till
you did that
he did not even care if they would
follow him after that in fact
like the story of the leopards one came
back
and thanked him thief on the cross all
these other things right there's so many
examples of that
jesus did it in despite how people would
react
even after that was done because he
cared that much about the people
and those people when they saw that
genuineness they said
what else do you know and i think if we
take that same sort of thing
right you start you start going out of
your way to help
people be kind to them and do all this i
guarantee they're going to pull you
aside and be like
what is it that you know how are you
like this because it's so foreign to the
world
that's right there's a saying you've got
to say it for this whole thing we're
talking about
people don't care about people don't
care about what you know until people
see that you care yeah that's the truth
they
don't i always say that it's by god's
grace they don't care
that we know all this doctrine that you
know the bible
until they actually see that you care
about them they don't care yeah you
don't want to hear that
they want people to care it's just like
you're saying jesus met
their felt needs first then he applied
the spiritual need
so we have to meet people if i see
somebody i mean that's actually a
biblical principle
because it says if you have a brother
that is in need of this world's goods
and you have
them you're supposed to give it to him
give it to him don't sit there well
you need to go to church or you no you
give him those needs and let god handle
the consequences
you take care of that physical need yeah
james talks about it too like if you see
somebody that's
cold and hungry don't just be like well
be blessed and be warm
you know you got to do something for him
and then he says i will show you my
faith by my works that's right you're
not doing you're not doing the works
they're in salvation
you're doing it because you are the
character of christ now and you
you want to give you want to you want to
take care of people so
i i i i would like to just throw this
out here but
a simple prayer is lord help me to see
people like you
see them that's it see people like them
and and
so many times you know we will you know
we'll just have a different set of eyes
when we're inviting christ in to see
the compassion and the and the way
through that and just
just throwing that out there for for
whatever it's worth
um you know in order to help people or
get involved or or to do things you know
just
it takes a lot of compassion and and you
know
we want to do that with the same way
that jesus would see those people
amen i like that i like that think about
people
and not numbers that's it yeah that's it
well i've been truly blessed by this
conversation thank you so much
darius for your time and coming in the
show and sharing with us
can you stay here for a whole another
week yeah
we barely scratch the surface man but
god's
grace god allows i'll come back you'll
have to you'll have to we welcome
you and uh definitely we we pray that
you guys are blessed by this we pray
that you would take this message to
heart
and and start thinking about how you can
become like christ an
image of christ and how you can have his
character and in
you know in a lot of our lives we reach
a place where it's like i'm sick of
myself
i'm god changed me like he said praying
that god was just
begging with god just take this from me
because i'm like a slave to sin
and he will set you free but he will
only do it when you surrender to him and
when you ask for him he's waiting for
you
to call upon him we love you we thank
you share this with all the people you
know and we'll see you next time
visit our brothers at school for
prophets dot tv and watch from babylon
to america which has over 5 million
views on youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more
[Music]
you